Netflix has enjoyed a bunch of well-deserved
success with their original content.
No commercials and fewer content restrictions
have given the the streaming service a clear
edge over other networks — and they don't
seem to be slowing down any time soon.
But with expanded original programming, not
everything can survive.
Since Netflix doesn't disclose their ratings,
the reason for a show's demise is sometimes
a mystery.
Here's a look at the real reason why Netflix
gave up on these shows.
Lilyhammer
Netflix's first outing into original programming
was Lilyhammer, about a mob fixer who enters
the Witness Protection Program after a failed
attempt on his life.
Co-writer and star Steven Van Zandt wasn't
too pleased about the show's cancellation,
writing on Twitter: "#Lilyhammer RIP.
Not my decision.
Let's just say for now the business got too
complicated."
Lilyhammer was produced in a partnership between
Netflix and the Norwegian government-owned
broadcasting company NRK.
Netflix chief content officer Ted Sarandos
cited the partnership as the source of the
decision to give Lilyhammer the axe, telling
The Hollywood Reporter,
"It was very difficult to maintain the level
of global exclusivity and control that we
hope to with our shows with [Lilyhammer] and
the way it was structured with the Norwegian
broadcaster."
Gypsy
Starring Naomi Watts as a therapist who oversteps
all boundaries with her patients, Gypsy was
cancelled only six weeks after its release.
Reviews were not kind, though many applauded
Watts and co-star Billy Crudup for their work,
given the subpar material.
The Telegraph described the show as…
"...flavourless hodgepodge."
And The AV Club said it was...
"...as subtle as syphilis."
Along with the critical bombing were reports
of an inflated salary for Watts.
Add to that the objections raised by Roma
organizations in regards to the series' title,
and it seems Gypsy was doomed from the start.
Haters Back Off
Netflix experimented with transporting a YouTube
character into a more traditional scripted
series with Haters Back Off, but apparently,
it didn't quite work as planned.
The show follows the inexplicable rise of
the talentless character Miranda Sings.
The reason for its cancellation doesn't seem
to be too much of a mystery.
Overall, the consensus seemed to be that the
transition from short YouTube clips of Miranda
Sings to half hour episodes wasn't easy.
According to the Los Angeles Daily News, while
Miranda's utter lack of talent might be hilarious
as a short video online, that simply doesn't
sustain a 30-minute show.
The Get Down
Baz Luhrmann's ambitious musical drama The
Get Down was canceled after one season — and
enough problems to fill a concert hall.
Variety reported that production delays became
so frequent that the writers started jokingly
calling the show "The Shut Down."
With a budget of $120 million, The Get Down
was reportedly the most expensive production
in Netflix history, which likely would have
been a huge factor in the decision to cut
the show.
But Luhrmann has said he believes the cancellation
had less to do with money and more to do with
his decision to walk away from the project
to work on a movie.
He addressed his fans on Facebook, saying:
"It kills me that I can’t split myself into
two and make myself available to both productions.
… But the simple truth is, I make movies."
Lady Dynamite
The unique and intense stand-up comic Maria
Bamford played herself in Netflix's Lady Dynamite.
Critics and viewers alike were thrilled with
this surreal comedy full of sharp critique
on Hollywood as well as painful humor about
mental illness.
Following the show's cancellation announcement,
some of Bamford's comments suggest she simply
couldn't continue with the production schedule.
Speaking to the AV Club, she described the
difficulty of working 15-hour days and the
irony of her work on the show, saying,
"It's hilarious because [Lady Dynamite] is
about mental health and that [I was] kind
of putting my mental health in danger in order
to do a TV show about mental health.
So, whoops."
Bloodline
The cancellation of Bloodline — a dramatic
thriller about a family reeling at the skeletons
uncovered in its closets — came as a surprise,
particularly considering the first season's
appeal to both critics and viewers.
Reception for the second season wasn't nearly
as positive as it was for the first, though
it seems likely the biggest factor in the
show's cancellation was the end of Florida's
entertainment tax incentive program.
Bloodline's budget benefited from what could've
been a much more expensive venture.
Once that changed — on top of a less positive
critical response — Bloodline's fate was
sealed.
Sense8
The cancellation of Sense8 after two seasons
was perhaps the most surprising of Netflix's
cuts to date.
Filmed in various cities across the globe,
the show was a hit with both fans and critics.
According to the Hollywood Reporter, Netflix
chief content officer Ted Sarandos said,
"The audience was very passionate, but not
large enough to support the economics of something
that big, even on our platform."
At a cost of $9 million per episode, Sense8
was simply too expensive to keep making.
Fan outcry was strong enough to merit an apologetic
response from Netflix on Facebook, saying:
"The reason we've taken so long to get back
to you is because we've thought long and hard
here at Netflix to try to make it work but
unfortunately we can't."
But later in the month, Netflix changed its
mind, greenlighting a special two-hour series
finale for Sense8 set for release in 2018.
Thanks for watching!
Click the Looper icon to subscribe to our
YouTube channel.
Plus check out all this cool stuff we know
you'll love, too!